after what has been a trial lasting over
three weeks or so has been found guilty
for the murder of Ellie Edwards
beautician he's shot dead outside the
lighthouse Pub in wallasey on Christmas
Eve 10 minutes before Christmas day he
intended to Target two other men rival
gang members from a distant from a
different estate to Connor Chapman
Kieran selkeld and Jake Duffy he's also
been charged he's also been found guilty
of attempted murder of those two men as
well there were other counts in this
trial as well where Connor Chapman has
been found guilty of wounding with
intent another count of wounding with a
tent and also causing actual bodily harm
he's also been found guilty with
possessing a firearm with intent to
endanger life and possessing ammunition
with intent to endanger life so in all
the counts that Connor Chapman was
charged with he has been found guilty
and of course that main one the murder
of Ellie Edwards the 26 year old woman
who was celebrating innocently on
Christmas Eve with her friends and
family in the lighthouse in in wallacy
on merseyside we were shot dead as she
went outside for a cigarette with her
friends just four minutes before the
gunman Connor Chapman who had been
laying in weight for around 55 minutes
in a car parking spot with a clear
unobstructed view of the entrance of the
pub came out he walked towards the
building and he fired 12 bullets into
the crowd of people he shot dead Ellie
Edwards and he injured five others too
that were his initial intended Targets
this has been a trial that's gone on for
three and a half weeks or so and here
are the background details of what went
on
this was nothing less than a cold callus
calculated attack just 10 minutes before
Christmas Day
[Applause]
foreign bullets from a lethal submachine
gun indiscriminately fired into a crowd
of people outside a pub injuring five
and killing one a jury said it was him
23 year old Connor Chapman today
convicted of murder
this 26 year old beautician a strong
caring innocent woman was not Chapman's
intended target but it was Ellie Edwards
while celebrating with her friends who
was caught in the middle of petty gang
rivalry two bullets to the back of her
head meant there was no chance of
survival he has taken the core of our
family
you ripped it out and
we'll never hit our Valley back
but it's never ever going to happen
but
she's always here
so we should be still half that
I'm not gonna allow him to take that
away from us
but throughout the trial Connor Chapman
denied it was him who drove a stolen
Mercedes to the lighthouse Inn that
night denied it was him who pulled the
trigger he said he was at home wrapping
Christmas presents this was a second an
attack by a ruthless and dangerous
individual it's uncomprehendable that's
that somebody would think that they
could get away with
um leaving the house possession of a gun
go into a pub that was packed and then
discharge a submachine gun into a crowd
that night changed the lives of many
people forever
Chapman did manage to seriously injure
the men he was targeting Kieran selkeld
and Jake Duffy both from a rival estate
they too were celebrating in the pub on
Christmas Eve this was no random or
chance attack Conor Chapman was out to
kill he arrived in wallasey just before
9 pm and waited in his car just over
there with a clear and unobstructed view
of the Pub's entrance all this before
seeing his targets approaching the
building and spraying bullets into a
crowd of people he was out here where
Ellie Edwards came for a smoke just four
minutes earlier she was simply in the
wrong place at the wrong time
and to convict the man responsible the
evidence was overwhelming red gloves
pictured on Chapman when he carried out
his attack seized from his friend's
address covered in his DNA along with a
bullet casing at the scene of the murder
the defendant then seen ruffling his
long hair and dropping the scorpion gun
as he walks towards his friend's house
just 12 minutes after the shooting the
CCTV footage was was played you look
directly at Connor Chapman
why was that
serious reaction
see if he had an any ounce of remorse
and from what I've seen so far he
doesn't care
it was clear Ellie Edwards was happy
enjoying life celebrating on Christmas
Eve all before it was brutally ended an
innocent woman whose family says she had
so much to give now we can begin again
it's a new chapter it's the beginning
of the future without Sally in Zaman
Rashid Sky News Liverpool
so imzibam this verdict in just in the
last few minutes this guilty verdict for
Connor Chapman found guilty of murdering
Ellie Edwards what was the reaction in
court
well our colleague inside Court's been
telling me that the family were in tears
they were incredibly happy as well when
that verdict of murder came through and
Ellie edwards's Father Tim who I spoke
to in that report there once again
looking directly at Connor Chapman as
those verdicts were read out to him as
he stood in the dock he told me that he
looked at Conor Chapman throughout the
trial to see if there was any ounce of
remorse from him any regret for what he
had done and Tim had found none the
family now outside the courtroom hugging
each other incredibly happy and
emotional with these uh verdicts it's
important as well to note that there was
a co-defendant on trial with Connor
Chapman Thomas Waring Thomas Waring a
criminal friend of Connor Chapman a
criminal Ally someone Connor Chapman
could trust the person where Connor
Chapman and had taken the murder weapon
to his home the person who had assisted
Connor Chapman in burning out that
Mercedes A-Class which was used on the
night he murdered Ellie Edwards Thomas
Waring has also been found guilty of
possessing a prohibited weapon and
assisting an offender that offender of
course being Connor Chapman now um the
family we are expecting shortly to come
out and say a few words alongside
merseyside police who said it was CCTV
that played a crucial role in this
investigation they trolled through I
think it was around 1 300 hours worth of
CCTV footage and of course it was that
essentially which was played to the jury
which was incredibly overwhelming the
footage not only of the moment Connor
Chapman fired 12 bullets into a crowd of
people but also seeing him ruffling his
hair dropping the murder weapon as he
walked towards his friend's house him
driving that Mercedes A-Class a car that
had been in his possession for around
three months before the attack had taken
place using false number plates
throughout that whole time he said it
was a pool car that other criminals had
used as well and then of course there
was the evidence in terms of DNA DNA
found on a red glove that Connor Chapman
had used on the night of the shooting a
builder's glove and DNA found on bullet
casing as well that was found at the
murder scene so I think the jury over
the last three and a half weeks I've
heard a wealth of evidence which
essentially boiled down to quite
overwhelming evidence to sway in the way
that Connor Chapman has today been found
guilty of the murder of Ellie Edwards
let's just recap it was 10 minutes
before Christmas Day Connor Chapman had
arrived at the Lighthouse Inn which was
absolutely packed as it usually is
almost every every year on Christmas Eve
where people mainly young people the age
of Ellie Edwards 26 were in that Pub
celebrating enjoying uh what was the
festive period and Connor Chapman had
arrived just before nine o'clock that
evening it essentially done a recce of
the area looking around the lighthouse
Inn and then he went and parked his
stolen A-Class Mercedes in the car park
of the lighthouse Inn and he watched on
he waited until he saw his targets here
in selkeld and Jake Duffy two members
from arrival Estates a rival gang to
Connor Chapman this was an ongoing feud
between these two gangs he then saw
those people he approached the building
and he fired what police say was
indiscriminately towards a crowd of
people it was just four minutes before
that firing that Ellie Edwards had gone
out with her friends into the beer
garden and had gone out for a cigarette
she was a holy innocent bystander in
this attack and I think that's really
what has been a a common um thread
throughout this whole case is that
people were saying this was Christmas
Eve Ellie was celebrating with friends
and family like millions of people were
doing up and down the country and she an
innocent bystander was shot in the head
with two bullets and they were
unsurvivable two other targets were
seriously injured the intended targets
and then three other men as well had
sustained injuries and just going back
to those verdicts for Connor Chapman the
23 year old who at all times had
completely denied his role in this
murder he had he had pleaded guilty for
one of the counts right at the beginning
that was possession of stolen goods that
the A-Class Mercedes however he had
pleaded not guilty to murder and
throughout the whole trial denied that
it was him who pulled the trigger which
killed Ellie Edwards but today the jury
found him guilty of her murder they
found him guilty of two counts of
attempted murder they found him guilty
of two counts of wounding with intent
they found him guilty of assault
occasioning actual bodily harm they
found him guilty of possessing a firearm
with intent to endanger life and found
him guilty of possessing ammunition with
intent to endanger life it's expected
that the judge will sentence Connor
Chapman tomorrow at around two o'clock
here at Liverpool Crown Court but when
we look at the reaction from the family
the sheer relief of people who for the
last six months have just been
questioning who was the person that took
Ellie Edwards life on Christmas Eve and
Tim Edwards her father had been very
emotional in court throughout the last
three and a half weeks but today in
particular it's clearly hit a man who
has been missing his daughter for the
last six months or so he was crying in
court he was incredibly emotional there
were shouts of yes in the public Gallery
the family had gone outside the
courtroom started hugging each other as
well and we are expecting for some of
the family members to come out and give
us their reaction as to what happened
but we go back and look back at the the
details of this case it was incredibly
overwhelming evidence that was presented
to this jury and I think the police Who
merseyside police who carried out this
investigation felt it was that evidence
that really what was what it was they
could put towards the jury here is the
family Tim Edwards there
very happy Tim do you want to come say a
few words
um
a few words we know that you want to you
talk tomorrow but just your reactions
now to what's happening in court today
yeah well we got the result we wanted
Justice for Ellie so it's always been
about
um
those two cows in there
decided to drag it out for four weeks
put all these people through that
and everyone else around it
involved in the case can't thank the
police enough for what they did and we
got there in the end and got live
results
and you know what I helped them to never
see another Christmas again have it in
their lives
tried to hide from you in the dock he
tried to keep his head so that he
couldn't see you I've had my eyes on him
for four weeks three weeks four I've
ever Long's been and he has not looked
at me once because he's a coward and
that's exactly what he is I mean I I
couldn't care less about him not even
I'll never ever mention his name and
I'll be rot in hell
how much of a relief is this
is this spoken to you for the last six
months ever since this happened how much
of a relief person is this it's a big
relief because now we can start again
we've been puffed through hell
and will be deserved now to be
given you know given the life back that
we're that we had before
which should never be the same
and freaking just it's just it's it's
now a new chapter that's a new beginning
for our family
big day indeed yeah it's it's the worst
day but the best of the worst I
that's all I'd say thank you everyone
although we have it Tim Edwards his
reaction to those guilty verdicts of
Connor Chapman the man who was bound
found guilty of murdering his daughter
on Christmas Eve 10 minutes before
Christmas Day and as he mentioned he was
trying to look at Connor Chapman that
man responsible for his daughter's death
he was hiding behind the glass in the
dock trying not to make eye contact with
Tim Edwards and what he's hoping is that
the two people remember there are two
people who have been found guilty here
today will not see another Christmas
again just like Tim Edward's daughter
will not it's been an emotional six
months for that family as you can
imagine and today will be a hugely
emotionally charged day as well um
Connor Chapman and Thomas wearing his
co-defendant his criminal Ally the court
heard the person where Connor Chapman
had taken they're going to his home the
person that helped him burn out the
A-Class Mercedes which was a stolen car
which Connor Chapman used on the night
of the murder will both be sentenced
tomorrow here at Liverpool Crown Court
and it is once again that CCTV footage
that merseyside police gathered
throughout their whole investigation
which played a crucial role in this
trial it was that which undoubtedly
convinced the jury over the last three
and a half weeks but just confirming
what has come out of Liverpool Crown
Court today six months after the murder
of Ellie Edwards Connor Chapman a 23
year old has today been found guilty of
her murder
the news from Liverpool Crown Court this
afternoon is that Connor Chapman 23
years old has been found guilty of the
murder of Ellie Edwards the 26 year old
beautician who was killed when he opened
fire with a submachine gun outside a pub
on Christmas Eve we heard from Tim
Edwards her father saying they got the
result they wanted it was Justice for
Ellie but he said he hopes that the
perpetrator rots in hell
now parliament's standards Watchdog has
recommended an eight-week suspension for
the former deputy conservative Chief
whip Chris pincher a report released
this morning found that Mr pincher
groped two people at a private members
Club in London last summer and concluded
that his behavior was completely
inappropriate